[Music]
your dresses have arrived
dearest viewer we've got the hottest
gossip in town today and it has to do
with the flawless costumes we know you
envied while watching netflix hit show
bridgeton
flawless my dear the gowns corsets and
jewels were no doubt
extraordinary but were they comfortable
in short
no but there's so much more that went
into the creation of this over-the-top
wardrobe and we've uncovered it all
ready for this 19th century carriage
ride
bridgerton definitely did not shy away
from showing us the realities of what
women suffered through when it came to
their outfits
especially in the upper class rankings
of the bridgertons and featheringtons
one of the series first scenes shows
prudence featherington
painfully getting her corset tightened
we're all here for impressing the queen
but her corset ended up being so tight
it cut off the oxygen flow in her body
and led to a very embarrassing moment
that basically wrecked all of her
prospects for the marriage season
we even saw the markings on daphne where
her corsets cut into her back
she just casually stood there getting
fitted into another corset though and
didn't even flinch we don't know whether
to be impressed with daphne or horrified
that that was the norm for women in 1813
as you could imagine so much went into
the making of these dresses
and costume designer ellen miragnik
spent months
even before the show began filming
making sure everything was perfect
but despite the accuracy and what
corsets feel like on women
the closets of the bridgerton characters
weren't exactly historically accurate
take a listen to ellen discuss how she
really wanted to make sure she also put
a modern twist on her words
this interpretation of 1813 needed to be
an overview of how can we
add modern elements to it while the
overall look of the dresses stayed in
line with the time
ellen added more lustfulness to the show
by lowering the necklines and making
everything
a little less modest it's a shonda
rhymes romance show after all
she made scrubs on grey's anatomy more
appealing
so why not 1813 fashion oh yeah
pants are definitely coming off nobody's
pants are coming off
another big change from the era were the
colors she used
were we the only ones who pressed play
and were ambushed by how bright the
screen was in the first three seconds
in a good way of course instead of
sticking to the color palette of the
time
she dressed the characters based on
their family and where they were
emotionally
for instance the bridgertons wear mostly
muted and classy colors while the
featheringtons opted for over-the-top
right floral patterns as a signal to
their new money
which didn't last very long we might add
if you pay close attention
daphne's wardrobe also shifts to darker
pieces as she grows more into an adult
and learns the dark truths of her new
husband and of marriage
while learning about what went into the
design process is great
let's discuss what everyone has been
waiting for were these costumes as
uncomfortable for the cast as they were
for women in the early 19th century
well we're gonna hope no one walked away
with markings like daphne
but the cast was pretty vocal about how
painful and irritating the show's
wardrobe could actually be
first up fittings in the wise words of
lizzie maguire's kate saunders
lizzie mcguire you are an outfit
repeater none of the bridgeton
characters were
outfit repeaters which is great for them
but
not so much for their actors never
wearing the same clothing twice meant
the actors spent
endless hours in the fitting room trying
on dress after dress
phoebe denver who plays daphne even said
fittings and seeing all the costumes in
person was actually
slightly terrifying no matter how pretty
a dress is
wearing a corset for hours is eventually
going to get old
but that wasn't the worst part during
fittings and during filming in general
the actresses would be afraid to eat or
do anything in fear of ruining one of
their costumes
nicola cochlin who brings penelope to
life said ruining her costume was
something she thought about the entire
time
one of these flowers that i have on this
dress is handmade it's embellished all
the jewelry is handmade put together
imagine having the stress of keeping
your costume intact while also trying to
give the director your best performance
the best or worst part of the whole
thing was that their way of preventing
any mishap with the costumes
was probably just as uncomfortable as
the corsets themselves
nicholas says she would have a big coat
put around her that would cover her
entire outfit
but that made it even more difficult to
do anything because it gave her
t-rex arms moving along to the actual
corsets
yep they were uncomfortable so
uncomfortable that nicola is demanding
she gets an award for even having to
wear one
i know there's some kind of corsetry
acting awards but i would like one
for doing a full jig in this it wasn't
easy they may not have had the corsets
tightened enough to deplete their oxygen
but they did put a lot of strain on
their ribs girls
you know that feeling of relief when you
finally get to take off your bra after a
long day
multiply that by ten thousand and that's
what nicholas says removing a corset is
like
taking off a corset at the end of the
day just feels incredible
it's a bra times ten thousand your ribs
are just like
ugh even ellen mirage neck admitted that
while the corsets were definitely less
intense
she doesn't think comfort comes into the
conversation unfortunately
there was just no how no way to make the
costumes as comfortable
as a sports bra our respect for the
bridgeton women is honestly through the
roof right now
would you be able to wear a corset for
hours on end we don't see much of these
in the show just because of how long
their gowns are but
shoes played a role in the added pain
the actors had to endure
especially for nicola because she was
more petite than the others they
originally had her in heels
that didn't go very well like it really
didn't go very well
she was constantly falling over and even
once injured her castmate claudia jesse
who plays eloise
take a listen to this hilarious story
she told good morning america
on the first day and fell over three
times in the heels
and stabbed claudia jesse who plays
eloise right in the hand and drew blood
well it's safe to say the costume
department scrapped her wearing heels
fairly quickly who would have thought
that undergarments apart from corsets
also played a huge role in the costumes
this piece of wardrobe may not have been
painful but it definitely sounds
uncomfortable bloomers were worn
underneath the extravagant dresses
crotchless bloomers yup you heard that
right
we'd be okay if we never had to wear a
pair in our entire lives
who's with us
the costume department might have been
ambitious with their dresses and corsets
but that doesn't mean they didn't at
least try to make the experience of
dancing in rib restraining material a
little more bearable
the costumes took an entire five months
of prep and over 200 workers to make
sure that the actors would be able to
move and bend while also
looking fabulous when it came to putting
the pieces together
each actor had their dresses custom fit
to their body even the extras that you
see gallivanting in the background of
balls
that way they'd all be able to move
around comfortably as much as possible
ellen may have been the genius behind
the designs of these dresses and a
literal
costume goddess but she wouldn't have
been able to bring
everything to life properly without the
help of mr pearl
a corset maker who's designed corsets
for celebs like kim kardashian
madonna and beyonce ellen praised him
immensely saying there are no two bodies
that are alike
if there is a bosom or a shape that has
to be adjusted for the costume
he knows how to create that structure to
be able to give you that
so ladies and gents without mr pearl it
looks like those corsets might
have been way less bearable ellen even
prided herself by saying
they were i think far more comfortable
than they ever thought they'd be
without denying that these actresses had
a lot to deal with while filming
they're definitely in debt to ellen her
over 200 person team and the one and
only mr pearl for really enhancing their
experience
all in all these costume designers and
filmmakers did the best they could to
both make these actors comfortable while
also bringing the intriguing world of
bridgeton to life
we can only hope that if there is a
season 2 they're able to bring to life
the exquisiteness we saw in season 1
once again do you have a favorite outfit
from the series
or a favorite character's wardrobe
you're obsessed with tell us all your
19th century wardrobe dreams in the
comments section below
maybe your gossip will make lady whistle
down's next column in society papers
yours truly the things